Vanessa Block ist zu Ende
[Musik]
für und
jetzt ist das Ende
nah und so stehe ich
vor dem letzten
Vorhang, mein
Freund, ich werde es
klar sagen, ich werde meinen
Fall darlegen, von dem ich
sicher bin, dass
ich ein erfülltes Leben geführt habe  Bin jeden einzelnen
Highway bereist und noch
viel mehr als
das. Ich habe es getan.
[Musik]
Ich bereue
einiges, aber auch ein
paar, die ich
erwähnen kann, ich
konnte
es nicht auslassen und habe es
ausnahmslos durchgehalten.
Ich
plane jeden aufgezeichneten
Kurs sorgfältig
Schritt auf dem
Nebenweg und
mehr, viel mehr als
das, ich habe es auf
meine Weise getan,
denn was ist ein
Mann, was hat er,
wenn nicht
sich selbst, dann muss er nicht die
Dinge sagen, die er wirklich
fühlt, und nicht die
Worte von jemandem, der
die Aufzeichnung braucht, zeigt
mir  Ich habe die Schläge einstecken müssen
und habe es auf
meine
[Musik]
Art gemacht,
ja, es war
[Musik]
meine
Art